chaos violence continues to rock the
entire Middle East with a conflict that
some believe could erupt into a major
global conflict and War but is the
biggest threat to America actually
coming from within because in every
major city every state there are
leftists who exhibit more Fidelity to
the people of Gaza uh than Americans who
are murdered and taken hostage by
terrorist by Israelis murdered and taken
hostage in fact for weeks now we have
witnessed some of these individuals make
excuse after excuse and in many cases
even celebrating the barbaric acts
perpetrated by the terrorist group Hamas
and even speaking out in support of
Hamas this is not a fringe group of L
lunatics either we're talking about
college professors many many college
students at our our finest universities
Health Care Providers Bankers prominent
celebrities even members of Congress
they clearly hate Israel and the Jewish
people that live there and supposedly
they loathe capitalism they detest the
very idea of America although they
really seem to enjoy living here but of
course this seditious hatred and bigotry
extends all the way to the East River in
New York where the United Nations is
rought historically with
anti-americanism and anti-Semitism for
example today listen to the UN Secretary
General and the list of excuses uh for
the actions the terrorist actions of
Hamas take a look
it is important to also recognize the
attacks by amas did not happen in a
vacuum the Palestinian people have been
subjected to 56 years of suffocating
occupation they have seen their land
steadily divor by settlements and
plagued by violence their economy
stiffled their people displaced and
their homes
demolished their hopes for a political
solution to their plight have been
Vanishing
I've said this for some time because of
the anti-americanism the veral and
anti-Semitism it is time frankly as far
as I'm concerned for the UN to be
evicted from America they are an
anti-American organization they serve no
purpose they take up valuable real
estate in New York City uh that it
doesn't deserve and we the taxpayers you
know we pay the bulk of monies just for
the privilege of being hated uh as well
as our closest Ally Israel and while
we're at it let's cut all ties and
funding to all these globalist
organizations the wh they covered up for
the Communist Chinese and Co the WF they
want nothing but worldwide Socialism or
the idiotic Paris climate Accords where
we pay the bulk of money and India and
China are recognized as developing
nations and pay next to nothing and by
the way while we're at it let's get rid
of every other anti-American globalist
organization when was the last time one
of these groups actually made anybody's
life better probably never so let's
invite the world's brainless spineless
self-important diplomats let them clog
the traffic of some other country I say
China let China have the UN and they can
spend the billions annually to to keep
that in failing institution running now
sadly we've come to expect this kind of
extremism from diplomats around the
world but it's far more shocking to see
the massive pramas protests on American
streets and city after city after City
people holding signs that call for a
global Islamic revolution others
praising the brutal actions of Hamas
including the rape the murder the
torture the families burned alive the
kids abducted the babies beheaded you
know some even ripping down posters
featuring The Missing American and
Israeli children now being held hostage
by Hamas this is evil it is happening in
real time in our time what kind of
person tears down a poster of a missing
child farle hatred bigotry is seemingly
everywhere in this country in numbers
that I don't think any anybody expected
and that's why the White House Press
Secretary Karine Jean Pierre was unable
to condemn anti-Semitism yesterday and
instead only wanted to talk about
islamophobia take a look at this what is
his level of concern right now about the
potential rise of anti-Semitism in light
of everything that's going on in Israel
so a couple of things um look um uh we
have not seen uh any credible uh threats
I know there's been always questions
about uh credible threats uh and so uh
just want to make sure that that's out
there but look uh Muslim and those
perceived uh to be Muslim have endured a
disproportionate uh number of hate
fueled attacks and certainly President
Biden understands that many of our
Muslim Arab AR Arab Americans and
palestini American loved ones and
neighbors are worried about the hate
being directed at at their Community
nice way to flip that anyway kjp later
clarified her remarks and said that she
misheard the question which seems to be
a very common theme in the Biden
Administration these days Joe misheard
the question two other times this week
now the Hamas sympathizers in the free
Palestine crowd are demanding that
Israel do nothing they're all calling
for a ceasefire after Israel has had the
worst terror attack on their soil in
their history now of course it would be
a one-sided ceasefire MOS is launching
thousands of rockets daily and has
previously broken every single ceasefire
that has ever been agreed to over the
years tens and tens and tens of
thousands of rockets have been fired
from Gaza from uh Lebanon Hezbollah into
Israel this has to end Israel cannot
function with that number of rockets
being fired at their country every
single solitary week the free Palestine
crowd they don't really want to seize
fire they just want to give Hamas more
time to reload resupply and while
they're at it probably setting booby
traps uh when the incursion of Israel
occurs now by the way the same crowd
doesn't actually want the Palestinian
people to be free because if that was
the case they would be calling for Hamas
to be annihilated the terrorist rulers
of Gaza they don't allow anyone to be
free there's no freedom of speech
there's no freedom of religion there's
no freedom of the press there's no free
and fair elections uh and look at how
they treat minorities many are executed
anyway but the free Palestine crowd they
don't care that would be too truthful
for them they don't care about Freedom
at all they just want Hamas to push
Israel into the sea and in the process
killing as many Jews as possible and
then they would justify it all away that
is what is in hamas's Charter that is
what they have vowed to do we should
start paying attention to their own
words but the hate the hysteria is now
so bad on the left that even Hillary
Clinton is getting heckled watch this
who ising speech President Joe Biden is
calling for1 billion of funding for
Israel Taiwan and Ukraine and we're
supposed to just bundle these together
and pretend like we're going to rush to
World War III and we're all just GNA
let I'm sorry you know this is not some
this is not the way to have a
conversation if you want to have a
conversation you're welcome to come talk
to me afterwards okay right you're going
to wait for me right I I will wait for
you and I will listen to you and I will
respond to you but right respectfully I
do not believe the matter is that the
American people's voice are what need to
be heard yeah they are being heard
president is not speaking for the
American people well that's your opinion
that's your opinion that's my opinion
but well then sit down we've heard your
opinion wow the left loves it when
Hillary Clinton lectures us about the
evils of stolen elections while
perpetuating the Russia hoax uh but they
just can't seem to tolerate her when she
voices support for Israel and meanwhile
former president Obama he's now more
than happy to lecture the country about
both sides of the conflict in the Middle
East also by the way Barack spare us
your lectures remember it was Obama who
was the first idiot as president that
sent billions to Iran in exchange for
absolutely nothing while Iranian proxies
were murdering American soldiers in Iraq
at the time Obama he was helping to make
them rich and naturally Biden picked up
where Barack left off and here we are on
the precipice of yet another War but
according to reports Biden is
encouraging Israel to delay the ground
Invasion to negotiate the release of
more hostages let me be clear nobody
wants every hostage uh released more
than I do every one of them including
every American but why on Earth the
Democrats put so much Faith and Hope
into the murdering terrorists who just
brutalized Southern Israel the ones that
were killing little babies and even
beheading them uh because that doesn't
seem wise it doesn't seem particularly
hopeful to me hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else